let's take you straight to the White
House where U.S President Joe Biden is
making an announcement about the M1
Abrams Tanks being sent to Ukraine let's
listen in 11 months in which Ukrainian
people have showed Putin and the world
the full force of their courage and the
indomitable determination to live free
and through every single step this
horrific War the American people have
been strong and unwavering their support
and Democrats and Republicans in
Congress have stood together
the United States has worked in lockstep
with our allies and partners around the
world to make sure you're Ukrainian
people are in the strongest possible
position to defend their Nation their
families and against the brutal the
truly brutal aggression of Russia I
haven't seen the likes of this in a long
time
the United States and Europe are fully
United
this morning
I had a long conversation with our NATO
allies German Chancellor Schultz friends
president macron prime minister Sanuk
and the Italian Prime Minister Maloney
uh to continue our close coordination
and our full support of Ukraine because
you all know I've been saying this for a
long time the expectation of the part of
Russia is we're going to break up we're
not going to stay United but we are
fully thoroughly totally United
with spring approaching Ukrainian forces
are working to defend the territory they
hold and prepared for additional counter
offenses
to liberate their land they need to be
able to counter Russia's evolving
tactics and strategy on the battlefield
in the very near term
they need to improve their ability to
maneuver and open Terrain
and they need an enduring capability to
deter and defend against Russian
aggression over the long term
the Secretary of State the secretary of
the uh of uh the military be behind me
uh are uh they they've been deeply
deeply involved in this this whole
effort armored capability as uh General
Austin will tell you to speak uh
is has been has been critical that's why
the United States has committed hundreds
of armored fighting vehicles to date
including more than 500 as part of the
assistance package we announced last
Friday
and today today I'm announcing that the
United States will be sending 31 Abram
tanks to Ukraine the equivalent of one
Ukrainian Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and achieve its strategic
objectives
Dave and thanks are the most capable
tanks in the world they're also
extremely complex to operate and
maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and the equipment necessary to
effectively sustain these tanks on the
battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see we'll use to make
sure the ukrainians are fully prepared
to integrate the Abram tanks into their
defenses
we're also closely coordinated this
announcement with our allies
the American contribution will be joined
by an additional announcement including
that will be will be ready to available
and more easily integrated for use in
the battlefield in the coming weeks and
months from other countries
I'm grateful to Chancellor Schultz
providing German Leopard two tanks and
will lead an effort to organize a
European contribution of two tank
battalions for Ukraine I want to thank
the chancellor for his leadership and
his steadfast commitment to our
Collective efforts to support Ukraine
Germany has really stepped up the
chancellor has been a strong strong
voice for Unity a close friend and for
the level of effort we're going to
continue
supported Ukraine's ability to fight off
Russian aggression to defend its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity is
a worldwide commitment not just looked a
worldwide commitment last week Germany
in Germany secretary Austin convened
Ukraine defense contact group for the
eighth time this group was made up of
some 50 Nations 50 Nations each making
significant contribution of their own to
Ukraine's integrity
each fully committed to making Ukraine
remain strong and independent and able
to defend itself against Russian threats
and violence
I want to thank every member of that
Coalition for continuing to step up
the UK the United Kingdom recently
announced that it's donating Challenger
two tanks to Ukraine France is
contributing AMX 10s armored fighting
vehicles
in addition to the leopard tanks the
Germany like the United States is also
Germany is also sending a pet a patriot
missile battery
the Netherlands is donating to
patriotism and launchers France Canada
the UK Slovakia and Norway and others
have all donated critical air defense
systems to help secure Ukrainian skies
and save the lives of innocent civilians
who are literally the target the target
of Russia's aggression
Paul was sending armored vehicles Sweden
is donating infantry fighting Vehicles
Italy is giving artillery Denmark and
Estonia are sending howitzers Latvia is
providing more Stinger missiles
lithuanians providing anti-aircraft guns
and Finland recently announced its
largest package of security assistance
to date you may remember what was asked
a while ago what I think was going to
happen and I said probably let's put no
he thought that he's going to end up
with a fennelization of Europe we've got
the natoization of Finland we've gotten
something he'd never intended
together with our allies and partners
we've sent more than 3 000 armored
vehicles
where the 8 000 artillery systems more
than two million rounds of artillery
ammunition and more than 50 Advanced
multi-launch rocket systems and I
shipment air defense systems all to help
counter Ukraine's brutal aggression
that's happening because of Russia
and you know today's announcement Builds
on the hard work and commitment from
countries around the world led by the
United States of America to help Ukraine
defend its sovereignty its territorial
integrity
that's what this is about helping
Ukraine defend and protect Ukrainian
land it is not an offensive threat to
Russia we are there is no offensive
threat to Russia if Russia troops return
to Russia they'll be there for this
where they belong this war would be over
today
that's what we all want an end of this
war
in just and Lasting terms
you know our teams do not permit One
Nation we're not going to allow one
nation to steal the neighbor's territory
by force
our terms preserve Russia's Sovereign
Ukrainian sovereignty and territorial
integrity and honor the U.N Charter
that's our favorite terms we're working
on
and you know these are these are the
terms we all signed up for and 143
Nations voted for in the United Nations
General Assembly last October
so the United States standing shoulder
to shoulder of allies and partners is
going to continue to do all we can to
support Ukraine Putin expected Europe
and the United States to weaken our
resolve he expected our support for
Ukraine to crumble with time he was
wrong
he was wrong he was wrong from the
beginning he continues to be wrong we
are united
America is United and so is the world
and we approached the one-year Mark as
we do of the Russian full-scale invasion
Ukraine we remain United and determined
as ever and our conviction and our cause
these tanks are further evidence of our
enduring unflagging commitment to
Ukraine and our confidence in the skill
of the Ukrainian forces
as I told president zielinski when he
was here and today is his birthday by
the way
in December we're with you for as long
as it takes Mr President
ukrainians are fighting an age-old
battle against aggression and domination
it's a battle America has fought proudly
time and again
and it's a battle we're going to make
sure the ukrainians are well equipped to
fight as well this is about freedom
freedom for Ukraine Freedom everywhere
it's about the kind of world we want to
live in the world we want to leave to
our children
so may God protect the brave Ukrainian
Defenders of their country
and keep the flame of Liberty Burning
Brightly as we can thank you Mr
President why are you taking this
decision now
did Germany force you to change your
mind on sending tanks
Germany enforcement changed your mind we
wanted to make sure we're all together
as we're going to do all that's what
we're doing right now thank you Mr
President any response to the Pence
disclosures of classified documents
Sarah the searches of your homes
completed Mr President that's the U.S
president Jay Biden is speaking about M1
Abrams tax been sent to Ukraine has
expected 31 tanks being sent uh parts
and equipment necessary to sustain the
tanks of the battlefield will also go
there training will take place he talked
how it will take time it didn't say how
much time but it will take time so the
Grateful the US is grateful to Germany
for the leopard two tanks that they have
committed and also for Europe and their
ongoing efforts to supply tanks in the
UK with their challenge attacks let's
bring in Kimberly Harker who joins us
now from outside the White House so
Kimberly uh the statement as expected 31
Abram tanks going to Ukraine
yeah the statement is what's expected
but a couple of things in there that are
important to know the first uh the
president is and you heard there the
reporter's question about the pressure
from Germany the reason for that
question is very simple it's uh because
this is a bit of a policy reversal for
the president given the fact that his
own Pentagon in generals were somewhat
resistant to sending these uh tags
because of the fact that they are
cumbersome you heard the president
acknowledging that there the fact that
this is an older technology the Abrams
tanks were designed back in the 70s and
although they have been upgraded they
operate on jet fuel so there's a
tremendous amount of logistics that is
involved in facilitating these on the
battlefield so you heard the president
talking there about how there is going
to be an enormous amount of training
that's going to be involved in getting
these up and running on the battlefield
for the ukrainians and that it's not
going to happen quickly and so you heard
the reporter there asking about the
pressure from Germany and the president
sort of saying that this was his
decision but this is certainly something
that's noted back here in the United
States the other important point to note
uh from the president's announcement is
that he made it very clear that this is
not an offensive threat to Russia and
the reason that he's saying that is
really more of a signal uh to Americans
here in the United States who might be
worried about Mission creep if you will
you have to remember Russia is a as a
nuclear power and there are many
Americans here who are watching this
very carefully worried about the
escalation and the impact this might
have back in the United States so the
U.S president speaking of as much to the
world as he is to a domestic audience
when he said that this is very much
about protecting Ukraine protecting the
sovereignty and making and a lasting and
enduring commitment to president
zielinski that this is about making sure
that ukrainians acted in nothing more so
this is certainly something that follows
on the heels of commitments that have
been made in terms of security
assistance on Capitol Hill from the U.S
president this is again though a policy
reversal the U.S president uh doing this
after much deliberation and again on the
heels of going against the advice of his
generals who were not inclined to send
these tanks because they can be
cumbersome and difficult to maintain on
the battlefield
all right Kimberly thanks for that Kimmy
Huck at the at the White House